California California nice been my
name's Ali hi free free like the cheese
brie yes pri yes besides we signed a
little bit I live next to an Islamic
Center for a while yeah so honestly not
not too much I would love to be educated
though I worship so we don't believe
that God is like we say there's nothing
making us not beginner easy because it
is nothing like actually well do is our
weed so it's not like so it's not so
like tied down to specifics it's it's
not like this came from the nation
[Music]
christians christians believe and this
is what makes its time like one of the
things that makes it really unique this
for a class here it says in the name of
allah say the truth is the allah is
grounded allah is be so of all needing
so allah does not need anything he is
free from community he does not beget
nor is He begotten here eat this you
know he doesn't have a child more [ __ ]
those who have a father mother or father
right and speak and equal to him is none
so now when you look at major religions
in the world will be Hindus they believe
in millions of millions of postback you
say when you look in charity they
believe that God came down
incarnated itself to Jesus and Jesus was
called and he died on the cross so any
other villages this world they go around
the same kind of thing what makes this
time different is because we say there
is nothing like go to yeah okay the
reason why a stamp came is to free
ourselves from slavery
no Tommy by the air because I know
people come and say for example I am
free I'm free anyway I come back not
really because you do not choose your
name
namely you choose to look how you look
same goes with me we do not choose your
mother and father
you do not choose your proper sister
your Heights jiangshan say yeah so if
you think of reality you're not actually
free free yeah so now every single one
of us are our slaves
yeah rule now but we choose what we're
going to be a slave to each other yeah
so it's Tom came to free man from the
slavery of human beings via a meezerman
beings with anything and to worship God
alone because we worshiping good is your
you find freedom to being a slave to the
one that deserves it yeah okay so when I
do you a favor and I say we go break
free yeah nice pretty yeah no hey go
break I'll give you a gift you're gonna
say thank you man yeah yeah this really
kinda quick of me no gift here however
with God Almighty we do not thank and
praise Him and pray to Him
because he what he does but because he
deserves it right yeah because it
deserved into the epic so it means even
if I didn't do nothing for you I'm just
give myself an example you thanking me
because I'm deserve another I am I'm
saying we've got all my days like that
so God has come to break those barriers
now what do I mean by that yeah I'll
give you my surface later I'm a river
system I can taste I'm too far
what major yeah this one of the things
that made me I was chasing the lifestyle
or black you know what we're totally
okay money cars clothes material I need
to go to the gym and if you look good
why they need to look good for myself no
cause girls like guys are being here so
I was in that mentality because I
believe I was a slave
I was displayed to a society where the
society excise telling me this is how
you read to me and this is how you say
yeah that's why I was a slave to that
and then what would do is I was thinking
about you yes that's my anger I want to
go and do this and do that but then I
would go ahead and ads I knew someone I
came from very wealthy guys
but he would say guy at night I'm
drinking up on this kinda puts me on the
force room with this guy because I'm
trying to be back this guy's here
because when you get there you realize
that you might not be happens with a lot
of people in those positions you say
they've tried everything and that's what
they gonna try for easy stuff like you
know I mean sex with animals and all
kind of stuff like you know I want to
try something new the nature you always
one more so I would look at this guy and
I think he'd run I'm gonna be like this
guy and this pattern is probably I don't
know what's going on was very what's
happening so that afterwards I have
remember dad my cousin committed suicide
he's been whammed himself in the park
stray off the he died my neighbor killed
himself like we understood that they
didn't have a belonging they did not
understand because when you don't
understand why you're here where you go
in this we can be messy because if up
you guys want to train and on that train
you have whatever you like anything at
one moment you're gonna say who put me
on the strain and where the string going
yeah okay but everything's calm but who
put me and where the trains going that's
the question that I ask myself okay
maybe seem good but where am i golden
chance eh
so then I realized when I had that
realization actually in these different
factors are playing that for example
back in the days I stuck on common
really so there was one specific jumper
that I really liked yeah okay you made
me look really good yeah that's why I
believe me when I look in the mirror
yeah well you know I look good but I
hated this jumper yeah it was one of
those shows that make you itch yeah I
don't know like I hated it but I bought
myself can you believe the state I'm in
now I'm wearing something because I look
good in there and I bloody hate it Hume
is a bigger sleeper than me yeah so I
came to the realization I'm actually a
swing oh no I think I'm thinking of me
I'm not because society is taught me how
to talk how to walk out of thing
everything yes how did you break
yourself so I said you know what I need
to break the shot visible shuttle here I
have to be myself and be a slave to the
one who is creating and deserving over
here the one who's giving me my eye my
hand the way I'm structured my food that
my drink my mother my father everything
around me where this all come from it's
a girl from nowhere so that's why I said
to myself
he's the one that's deserving of worship
and when I worship Him I free myself
from and so what that means is I don't
care whether I jump anymore I don't want
to go to the gym cause girls like it I
don't want to drive all the thought you
said forgets it all and just clean wiped
all of and that's when I found my true
freedom yeah I'm living for other people
me because you know I didn't say do not
even like left uni what is it going to
mean when it's cold even economy-wide so
when the family members come home I'm
gonna go uni and get 35 grand a track
and go to my granddad me that look I
made it and then he's gonna be like okay
good and ready to go home now I was like
I don't wanna go down that route so
that's why even today the thing that
happens especially in females you guys
are making do you say even though like
like obviously we understand that
everyone has the insecurities translate
for but the thing is we believe as
females you guys are you are not a
sexual object
you can say yes I shall be I'm thinking
what have you got to do the top what
have you got to do with the car that
became these females like off naked on
top of comfortable that's that's the
media and that's like propaganda like
reinforcing itself and like pushing
their kind of beliefs on you to sell a
product it's all about selling a product
exactly so what are they doing they're
using a human being and dropping it down
to a level where she's not even human
and they said ok you're like you're like
the chocolate here yeah we want you to
come and you know he's your probably you
know another kind of chocolate he goes
from all the shoulders and what we're
seeing is that that's
that's wrong that's not that's not right
I'm trying to say yes because they're a
human being as a female you are someone
that should be respected to get your
mother your sister your daughter yeah we
should respect respect that's why when I
spoke to exacting I I refer to you as a
sister
yeah cuz I respect you I don't see you
as you know just do some next time same
and that's why the society has sadly
made I look up you know sometimes when
they were heroes and he's bleeding no
it's not genuine I'm thinking like
doesn't it hurt but the question that I
know I'm gonna get back is like I would
put in it see I'm trying to say yeah and
reminds me of me you know so the issue
is that this mom came for us to
acknowledge and worship God because we
believe in the Quran Allah says but
indeed with the remembrance of your Lord
o do hearts find peace here so if you
forget my remembrance whatever the first
time so we won't believe that there's
physical laws and metaphysical noise
yeah okay so I know if I drop my fault
let's parity yet so God is Buddhism
please Apple law in place but it happens
that that there's also metaphysical
goals that we don't see what that means
is Allah has programmed all of our
hearts God Almighty has programmed all
of our hearts that we only find
happiness with asthma memories that's
like a done deal here so that's the
reason why when people have for example
you look at them you know here money
cars revving adjacent there's always
this point yeah and what happens is you
feed the soul the wrong food here as you
feed your body you give it nutrition you
know if you don't your body is gonna
start acting yeah so the same way your
soul is dying your so the same would
give me the right kind of medicine that
means I say the food so what we believe
is that that's remembering God the heart
finds peace by remembering
that's why Islam came to get rid of
I don't you which is like worshiping
statues those people that would make
statute in their own hands and they were
worshipping and you're like look you
just made that yourself so what is
thunders it's time to come to a Polish
man from that slavery and concentrate
only as specifically to God Almighty
yeah you can say so that's the reason
why it's Thomas Thomas main fundamental
thing is to acknowledge people that God
is deserving of worship do you believe
yes ok no ok ok so that's what makes you
I think just yeah family also just I had
to abandon it to realize that I needed
it again you know I me because I was
Catholic for a while my parents got
divorced we got treated terribly by the
church because divorce is not really an
option for us there and so you know when
you just start getting treated badly
because of things kind of that change
you know people change people get
divorced it happens I just kind of
abandoned it and then I tried to
experiment and like see what other
religions had to offer and then my event
of everything and I had to like look
within myself and kind of like take a
self journey to realize that I needed
God again but in a different way you
know it's it's it's a version of God
that I have come to like accessing that
helps me like spiritually and like
everyday through a journey that I you
know accept in worship but I don't have
like I don't have a very specific place
to put in he just is and I accept that
kind of I mean
I did when they believe when I was going
yeah
[Music]
the more I put them off more I
disrespected him and
and you feel energies to like more the
more you accept the more that you feel
and to okay so we won't have a common
ground as we all believe that high
intelligence so can we come to an
agreement or do you believe that high
intelligence can be a month well I don't
know anytime we have something called
the fit from this position okay it's
something that even if someone says it's
right so for example so for example we
should all agree that God is Almighty
and this is the most powerful yeah yes
okay if God becomes a man man has to eat
this man has to be yes so why we say why
we why we reject the concept of man
being accordion man is because man I'm
limited to get it
good is the most powerful God becomes a
man he has to be it doesn't be written
because don't worry about our premise
here he has to be deserted of worship
yeah yeah okay you're not gonna you
gonna worship it's true oh yeah why not
I don't have reason to exactly so you're
looking at you thinking it doesn't
deserve to be worship because it relies
on something yet you want to worship
something that doesn't rely on nothing
I'm trying to say so that's why we've
got Almighty we say that with the
Christians we say that he cannot be a
man because a man eats food he has about
toilet he has weaknesses he is tired he
has to sleep that's not worthy of
worship because we're not worshiping we
might be sleeping the same
I'm taking time out here and we're
saying well that's not really God
Almighty
because if you're God Almighty you
shouldn't be sleeping you get you're the
most powerful you've made all of this
however is deep in Tennessee so that's
why that make sense yes
[Music]
we are us we are all connected he has
created this earth to live off of
something so he feeds us he keeps the
earth mother nature he's brought the
street why would we create out so we
didn't need us and become into something
I think but I think that we have learned
more and we do need to get home thank
you so much thank you thank you you will
respect me by shaking but obviously we
don't shake hands with you oh okay fine
so I'll pretend you know just quickly
explain the hand shakin because the
wrong way around hope you guys enjoyed
the video don't forget to share
subscribe and like and join the dowel
movement by becoming a dowel movement
member now
click the link below